aquí tenemos la reacción para un
acumulador de plomo aquí tenemos plomo
sólido más dióxido de plomo nos produce
sulfato de plomo y nuestro objetivo es
balancear esta reacción redox en
solución ácida así que para un
acumulador de plomo estamos tratando con
ácido sulfúrico y en un vídeo anterior
ya hemos hablado de cómo balancear una
reacción redox en una solución ha sido
así que en este vídeo simplemente
haremos un repaso de esto utilizando el
acumulador de plomo como un ejemplo así
que lo primero de lo que quiero hablar o
de lo que quiero hacer es asignar
estados de oxidación y vamos a empezar
con el plomo sólido y en este caso el
estado de oxidación de un elemento
simplemente es cero ahora nos movemos
hacia asia el dióxido de plomo y para el
oxígeno el estado de oxidación es
-2 cierto en este caso es menos 2 pero
tenemos dos de ellos lo cual nos da un
estado de menos cuatro en total cierto
vamos a ponerlo por ejemplo acá de este
lado
y sabemos que la suma de los estados de
oxidación en un compuesto neutral debe
ser cero así que en el caso del plomo su
estado de oxidación debe ser más cuatro
verdad en este caso será más 4 perfecto
ahora nos movemos al sulfato de plomo y
sabemos que el sulfato de plomo o más
bien sabemos que el sulfato verdad que
es el 04 es menos 2 aquí en este caso
tiene un estado de menos 2 y entonces
estamos trabajando con plomo 2 positivos
verdad en este caso será plomo 2
positivo así que el plomo su estado de
oxidación es 2 positivos entonces vamos
a escribir nuestra semi reacción de
oxidación muy bien empecemos con la semi
reacción de oxidación para lo cual
tenemos que preguntarnos qué es lo que
se está oxidando verdad y en este caso
el plomo sólido está yendo de un estado
de oxidación 0 verdad se está yendo a un
estado d
es positivo entonces este es un aumento
en el estado de oxidación y en este caso
estamos hablando de la oxidación así que
podemos escribir nuestra semi reacción
verdad en donde tenemos plomo sólido
verdad que se está digamos convirtiendo
en plomo 2 positivo pero sabemos que
tenemos sulfatos presente verdad así que
tenemos que poner el sulfato en ambos
lados así que tenemos plomo sólido
cierto
s o 4 que en este caso es 2 negativo
verdad y esto nos produce sulfato de
plomo ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
fijarnos en nuestros átomos que tenemos
en esta semi reacción verdad del lado
izquierdo
tenemos un plomo del lado derecho
tenemos un plomo del lado izquierdo
tenemos un azufre del lado derecho
también y del lado izquierdo tenemos 4
oxígenos del lado derecho tenemos 4
oxígenos así que todos nuestros átomos
están balanceados
ahora vamos a balancear la carga muy
bien y si balanceamos la carga podemos
hacerlo añadiendo por ejemplo electrones
así que vamos a tratar de ver cuántos
electrones hay que agregar y por
supuesto tenemos que ver donde agregar
los muy bien en el lado izquierdo verde
verdad tenemos dos cargas negativas
mientras que del lado derecho la carga
total es
muy bien así que para poder balancear la
carga tenemos que agregar 2 electrones y
esos 2 electrones los tenemos que
agregar del lado derecho y ahora bien
nuestras cargas están balanceadas verdad
y recordemos simplemente que la
oxidación es la pérdida de electrones
así que en esta semi reacción que está
ocurriendo verdad en el ánodo de nuestra
batería digamos se están perdiendo los
electrones justo están estos dos
electrones del lado de los productos muy
bien así que esta es la semi reacción en
el ánodo de la batería ahora queremos
hacer la semi reacción de reducción muy
bien así que vamos a ver cómo se haría
esto la semi reacción de reducción por
ejemplo en este caso podemos ver que
vamos de plomo que tiene un estado de
oxidación más 4 a un estado de más 2
cierto así que en este caso estamos
hablando de la semi reacción de
reducción cierto entonces esta semi
reacción sería plomo más bien dióxido de
plomo se convierte en
plomo dos positivos muy bien y
nuevamente recordemos que tenemos que
agregar los sulfatos que están presentes
verdad así que del lado izquierdo
tendríamos dióxido de plomo más sulfatos
cierto 2 negativo y esto nos produce
plomo perdón sulfato de plomo
ahora tenemos que balancear nuestros
átomos así que vamos a empezar con el
plomo empecemos con el plomo y tenemos
un plomo del lado izquierdo y un plomo
del lado derecho muy bien ahora que
hemos hecho eso vamos a ver qué pasa con
el azufre tenemos un azufre del lado
izquierdo y un azufre del lado derecho
muy bien ahora fijémonos en el oxígeno
fijémonos en el oxígeno del lado
izquierdo tenemos 2 oxígenos aquí y 4
oxígenos acá eso nos da un total de 6
oxígenos mientras que del lado derecho
tenemos sólo 4 oxígenos muy bien
4 oxígenos del lado derecho y para
balancear el número de oxígenos tenemos
que agregar agua verdad así que tenemos
que agregar 2 oxígenos del lado derecho
lo cual se puede obtener añadiendo 2
moléculas de agua muy bien entonces
agregamos dos moléculas de agua y ahora
tenemos el número adecuado de oxígeno es
verdad simplemente hemos agregado dos
moléculas de agua pero ahora tenemos que
balancear los oxígenos añadiendo el
protón es verdad que son esencialmente
hidrógenos positivos verdad así que
fijémonos del lado derecho cuántos
tenemos en realidad aquí tenemos dos h
dos que en realidad son cuatro
hidrógenos muy bien son cuatro
hidrógenos y del lado izquierdo no
tenemos hidrógeno es verdad así que
tenemos cero hidrógenos necesitamos
agregar cuatro protones del lado
izquierdo verdad tenemos que agregar
cuatro protones del lado izquierdo así
que ya tenemos balanceados los
hidrógenos ahora tenemos que balancear
la carga
verdad así que fijémonos en la carga
total del lado izquierdo bueno nosotros
tenemos cuatro cargas positivas verdad
tenemos cuatro cargas positivas aquí
tenemos dos cargas negativas verdad
entonces esto nos da una carga total de
2 positivo que tenemos una carga total
de 2 positivo mientras que del lado
derecho sería una carga total 0 verdad
tendremos una carga total 0 así que
tenemos que agregar verdad tenemos que
agregar electrones del lado izquierdo
para que podamos balancear la carga así
que aquí tenemos que agregar 2
electrones y con esto ahora sí tenemos
nuestra semi reacción de reducción que
ocurre en el cátodo de nuestra batería
verdad así que ahora tenemos que agregar
un perdón tenemos que sumar nuestras dos
semi reacciones juntas verdad y podemos
hacer esto porque tenemos el mismo
número de electrones así que vamos a
digamos
estas dos semi reacciones esta sería la
primera semi reacción y notemos que
estos dos electrones se cancelarán con
estos dos electrones verdad entonces
esta será la segunda semi reacción esta
es la segunda semi reacción y fijémonos
que es lo que obtenemos fijémonos
primero en los reactivos que tenemos
aquí acá arriba sería plomo sólido más
sulfato verdad
2 - y ahora fijémonos en los reactivos
que tenemos en esta semi reacción de
abajo serían serán 4 hidrógenos 4 h más
más dióxido de plomo más sulfato verdad
eso es lo que tenemos aquí abajo y eso
nos produce bueno fijémonos ahora en
este reactivo de arriba sería sulfato de
plomo
otro sulfato de plomo verdad y dos
moléculas de agua así que sería sulfato
de plomo más dos moléculas de agua y por
supuesto ya no nos importan los
electrones porque ya los hemos cancelado
vamos a ver si podemos simplificar
todavía un poco más esto vamos a tener
lo siguiente tendremos este plomo será
plomo más vamos a poner este el dióxido
de plomo y óxido de plomo y ahora
podríamos poner los cuatro hidrógenos
verdad 4 h más y fijémonos que aquí
tenemos dos sulfatos así que esto lo
simplificamos como 2s o 42 - y eso nos
produce verdad ahora otra vez podemos
fijarnos que tenemos dos sulfatos de
plomo
sulfatos de plomo y dos moléculas de
agua cierto que serían estas dos últimas
así que finalmente lo hemos logrado ya
tenemos la reacción total para una para
un acumulador de plomo y a veces puede
ser que encuentres esta parte escrita un
poquito distinto en ocasiones toman dos
de estos hidrógenos positivos
con estos dos sulfatos para obtener 2h s
o 42 - verdad y por supuesto nos faltan
los otros dos h más verdad entonces en
algunos libros de texto encontrarás esto
escrito de esta forma simplemente es
otra forma de escribirlo verdad y esto
esencialmente es lo que ocurre en la
celda voltaica verdad obtenemos un
voltaje a partir de esta reacción redox
espontánea y cada una de estas celdas
tiene de voltaje 12 volts positivos
verdad tenemos
2 volts positivos y por supuesto si
tomamos 6 de estas celdas entonces
simplemente sumamos el voltaje verdad
para obtener la batería digamos de un
cargo o el voltaje de la batería de un
carro que nos da un total de 12 volts en
esencia cuando la batería del carro se
descarga verdad
en realidad la reacción redux espontánea
le libera una corriente y así es como
nuestra digamos nuestro motor del carro
arranca así que una vez que nuestro auto
digamos ya está avanzando entonces la
reacción es revertida y eso nos permite
recargar nuestro acumulador de plomo así
que la reacción inversa verdad se puede
realizar y esto es porque tenemos
sulfato de plomo sólido verdad en este
caso el sulfato de plomo es sólido
verdad y eso lo podemos ver también en
nuestras semi reacciones vamos a verlo
aquí aquí nuestro sulfato de plomo es
sólido en este caso también es sólido y
de ahí es que una vez que hemos
encendido el auto verdad la reacción es
inversa
están listas para realizarse y por eso
es que podemos recargar la batería
verdad así que primero podrías pensar en
esto como una celda voltaica que produce
una corriente utilizando una reacción
redox espontánea y luego podríamos
pensar esto como una celda electrolítica
verdad una corriente estado siendo
utilizado para recargar nuestra batería
verdad y una corriente está siendo usada
para llevar a cabo una reacción que no
es espontánea verdad así que un
acumulador de plomo es recargable y eso
es bastante útil en las baterías de auto
porque eso permite que tengan una larga
duración